[موسيقى]
يستمر وقف اطلاق النار في السودان بعد ان
دخل حيز التنفيذ صباح اليوم في جميع انحاء
البلاد لمده 24 ساعه وذلك برعايه سعوديه
امريكيه وافاد مراسل الجزيره بسماع دوي
اطلاق نار متقطع في العاصمه بعد بدء سريان
وقف اطلاق النار كما شوهدت اعمده الدخان
تتصاعد في سماء العاصمه واشار مراسلنا الى
ان الطائرات الحربيه قصفت قبل دقيقتين من
بدء سريان الهدنه الجديده موقعا جنوب
الخرطوم بحري بينما ردت المضادات الارضيه
على هذا القصف ويستمر تصاعد اعمده الدخان
مع استمرار الحرائق لليوم الرابع على
التوالي في منشاه للنفط والغاز عقب هجوم
على مجمع اليرموك العسكري للصناعات
الدفاعيه جنوبيه
ان الخرطوم ينضم الينا مراسلنا اسامه سيد
احمد اسامه ما الذي تطور في سريان الهدنه
حتى الان
بالهدنه التي تم الاتفاق عليها ما بين
الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع هدنه
اليوم الواحد خلال الساعات الاولى من هذا
اليوم او قبل بدايه سريان الهدنه التي
دخلت حيزه تنفيذ بالفعل عند تمام الساعه
السادسه صباحا بتوقيت الخرطوم هذه الهدنه
حاولنا ان نرصد الشوارع وطبيعه الحياه
خلال هذه الهدنه في بداياتها وفي ساعات
الاولى الان نحن الان في واحد من اكبر
واهم شوارع الخرطوم وهو شارع المطار نحاول
ايضا ان يعني نرصد بالكاميرا كذلك هذا هو
مركز عفراء للتسوق واحد من اكبر واهم
مراكز التسوق في الخرطوم طبعا كان واحدا
من بؤره التوتر وكذلك شهدت هذه المنطقه
عموما يعني هذه المنطقه عموما شهدت
اشتباكات عنيفه ما بين الجيش السوداني
وقوات الدعم السريع طبعا تشاهدون الاثار
المدمره لهذه الاشتباكات التي طارت هذا
المكان
تاثيرات الحريق وتاثيرات ان كانت هنا
اشتباكات وكانت هنا طبعا هذا المكان كان
يضج في طبيعته في طبيعته بالحياه وحركه
المواطنين والاسر ولكن الوضع بدا هنا
مغايرا اذا للغايه الحريق طال اغلب يعني
اماكن واجزاء هذا المركز الذي تحول بعضه
الى رماد بشكل كامل هذه المنطقه وغيرها من
المناطق التي اشتباكات عنيفه ما بين الجيش
وقوات الدعم السريع هنا كثير من التفاصيل
تبدو يعني في غايه في غايه
الدمائر خاصه بعض
المراكز التجاريه والمحال التي هي الان
مغلقه طبعا بشكل كامل تاثيرات القصف
وتاثيرات الاشتباكات هنا تبدو واضحه طبعا
على هذا المركز وغيره من الاماكن التي بدت
في غايه الخراب سباق كان في هذا المكان او
كذلك ربما في اماكن اخرى يعني خلال وصولنا
الى هذا المكان رصدنا بالعين طبيعه
الشوارع وطبيعه المحاله التجاريه والمطاعم
وكذلك كثير من الاماكن التي اعطالها
الحريق
الدمار نتيجه
لاستمرار
الاشتباكات العنيفه ما بين الجيش السوداني
وقوات الدعم السريع طبعا خلال مشاهداتنا
حتى وصولنا الى هذا المكان لاحظنا خلو
الشوارع طبعا من الماره وخلو الشوارع طبعا
كذلك ايضا من السيارات حركه السيارات تبدو
منعدمه تماما طبعا اغلب الاسر واغلب الاسر
رحلت من اماكنها طبعا هذه تاثيرات القصف
قطع
لاسلحه تتناثر هنا وهناك وكذلك حريق ورماد
طالع هذا المكان كثير من الاماكن ايضا
وشوارع طالها
الحريق وصالها الدمار بشكل يبدو واضحا
للعين حتى وصلنا الى هذا المكان ولكن طبعا
استمرار هذه
الاشتباكات الان توقف خلال الساعات
الماضيه ولم نرصد اي شكل من اشكال
المواجهات القتاليه المستمره المباشره ما
بين الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع سوى القصف
الجوي الذي طالع مواقع بالخرطوم بجنوب
الخرطوم بحري ولكن هذه هذا الواقع كان قبل
بدايه السياره ريان الفعلي
للهدنه هدنه يوم الواحد
اسامه سيد احمد كنت معنا من الخرطوم